وقد اعلن جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي صباح
اليوم مقتل ضابط وجنديين في معارك شمال
قطاع غزه كما اعلن اصابه 44 عسكريا في
معارك القطاع في الساعات ال 24 الماضيه
وقالت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه ان قتلى
اليوم الثلاثه ينتبهون الى كتيبه شكيد
بلواء جفعاتي وان احدهم نائب قائد سريه
وقد قتلوا في شمالي القط
وتاتي حصيله قتل الجيش الاسرائيلي الجديده
بعد اعلانه امس مقتل خمسه ضباط وجنود
بينهم قائد سريه في لواء ناحال من قوات
النخبه وبذلك يرتفع عدد قتلى الجيش
الاسرائيلي المعلن منذ بدء العمليه البريه
في غزه الى 170 كما يرتفع العدد الاجمالي
لقتله منذ السابع من اكتوبر تشرين الاول
الماضي الى
498 بين ضابط
وجندي وفي العواجل التي ترد الينا كتائب
القسام تتحدث عن قصف تجمعين ليات وجنود
الاحتلال شمال مدينه خان يونس بقذائف هاون
من العيار الثقيل الان ينضم الينا من غلاف
غزه مراس الجزيره الياس كرام الياس وسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه قالت ان ان قتل اليوم
الثلاثه ينتمون الى كتيبه شكيد بلواء
جفعاتي وان احدهم نائب قائد سريه ماذا في
تفاصيل هذا النبا
بدايه بالفعل فد وهم ينضمون بطبيعه الحال
الى عشرات الجنود القتلى في العمليات
البريه وعشرات الجنود الجرحى الذين اعلن
عنهم الجيش الاسرائيلي في تقريره الرسمي
ظهر هذا اليوم حيث اشارت اخر النتائج الى
الى ان 44 عسكريا اسرائيليا اصيبوا في
معارك الساعات ال 24 الماضيه في داخل قطاع
غزه ومن الناحيه التراكميه فدا في الايام
الخمسه الاخيره نحن نستطيع ان نشير الى
نحو
250 عسكريا اسرائيليا اصيبوا بجروح معظمهم
بجروح خطيره للغايه او متوسطه هذا بحسب
البيانات الرسميه للجيش الاسرائيلي وهذه
الارقام فد تشير وتدلل على ان المعارك ما
زالت على اشدها في كل المناطق الجنود
الذين اصيبوا واعلن عن مقتلهم صباح هذا
اليوم قتلوا في المعارك التي جرت في
المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه التي كان يقول
الجيش الاسرائيلي بانه سيطر عليها لاتيا
وناريه في الايام الماضيه لكن واضح بانه
لا سيطره على الارض للجيش الاسرائيلي في
اي من المناطق وهذه المناطق ما زالت تشهد
حتى وفق بيانات الجيش الاسرائيلي معارك
ضاريه مع المقاومه الفلسطينيه حي الشجاعيه
التي ق قال الذي قال الجيش الاسرائيلي
بانه سيطر عليه ناريا وعمليا في الايام
الماضيه شهد ايضا قصفا جويا وشهد ايضا
اشتباكات مع المقاومه الفلسطينيه بحسب
بيانات الجيش الاسرائيلي المناطق الشماليه
والاحياء الشماليه لمدينه غزه كانت ايضا
في الساعات الاخيره عرضه لقصف مدفعي ولغات
جويه عنيفه ومن الواضح انه في الساعه
الاخيره الساعه الاخيره حملت معها ايه
كثير من الغارات الجويه وتحليق مكثف
للطيران الحربي الاسرائيلي وللمحيط
العسكريه التي جابت اجواء المنطقه وغارت
على مناطق بعينها في تحديدا في الاحياء
الشماليه لمدينه غزه لكن هذه الغارات
الجويه وهذا القصف المدفعي العنيف كان
يتركز في الساعه الاخيره تحديدا عند منطقه
المغرا وجحر الديك وتلك المناطق الواقعه
ايضا بين هذه المناطق و مخيمي البريج
والنصيرات حيث ان الجيش الجيش الاسرائيلي
قال بانه اطلق عمليه عسكريه او هجوما
باتجاه البريج وواضح بان الجيش الاسرائيلي
يحاول ان يعمق من عملياته العسكريه من
خلال هذا القصف المدفعي والغارات الجويه
الشديده على تلك المناطق الفرقه 36 التي
كانت بدات العمليات العسكريه البريه فدا
في اليوم الاول للعمليات البريه ودخلت
واجتاحت المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه عند
بيت لاهيا وبيت حنون هي التي تقوم الان في
عمليه التوغل في منطقه جحر الديك التي
تشهد ايضا بين الحين والاخر اشتباكات
بالاسلحه الرشاشه الخفيفه والثقيله وكذلك
هي التي تعمل وتحاول ان تتوغل فيما يعرف
بمخيمات بالمخيمات الوسطى اي البريج
والانصراف وربما بعد ذلك ايضا المغازي
ودير البرح هذه هي المناطق التي يحاول
الجيش الاسرائيلي ان يوسع من عملياته
العسكريه فيها فيما تتواصل ايضا العمليه
العسكريه في يونس الجيش الاسرائيلي قال في
اخر تحديث له هناك بان فرقه او وحده
الكوماندوز تقوم بتعميق عملياتها العسكريه
في المدينه وتعمل على الوصول الى الانفاق
الهجوميه والى مقار حركه حماس في تلك
المناطق في شكرا لك الياس كرام مراسل
الجزيره من غلاف غزه